why
so many of these young guys are
struggling with women what's your take
on it man you've been live in the uh
chat tonight
in here and there
i think one thing i'm not sure if you
hit on the skull but i think something
that gets overlooked quite a bit is the
emergence of
um or how
easy it is to get
porn on your phone these days and how
readily available it is
yeah so you mentioned that and i did
you know i did sort of uh touch on that
a little bit because
porn was available everywhere like i
first tripped across porn when i was
like 10 at my uncle's place and i came
across like an old magazine and it's
like everywhere i went throughout my
teen years there was always magazines
available they were just everywhere so
it's like i get it there's now free
streaming porn on on any device you want
but i mean if you want to be
if you want to be rich
then you can't point and sputter at porn
if you want to be with women you can't
point and sputter at porn if you want to
be
fit instead of fat you can't blame porn
i mean it's just a um a cop in my view
but
see the difference between me and a lot
of the other guys out there that create
in the space for guys we call it the
manoswamp now that's what i call it
anyway
um
is that i actually came here
as somebody that had done something of
some significance in their life prior
right so to me it's
it was like okay i've been driving a car
my entire life i know where the gas goes
i know how to shift i know what the
clutch pedal does
the only thing that the red pill really
did for me was it just showed me exactly
how the internal combustion engine
worked
right what timing is why that's
important the air fuel ratio the
mixtures that's all that that really
brought me to right so it's like when
guys start to say things like well you
know you have to give a little more you
have to what did that guy say in the
instagram post mop something about you
have to give some more recognition to
the in cell guys or whatever it was yeah
talk about the
pandemic or endemic or get more
attention or discuss it etc all of us
you me jiren were at one point wanting
to be intimate with women and were
unsuccessful yeah
we're i mean we're all in cells at one
point it's just you know
do you do enough work to level up and
work past that or are you going to let
that be your crush
well i think also when you talk about
incels i mean
you've got legit like inside like can
not for the life of them get a girl to
look their way or give me any sort of
attention but i think far more men maybe
not far more i'd be interested to see
what you guys thoughts are on this but
a lot of guys i think fall into the
category of
the women that want them they don't want
and the women they want don't want that
right so it's like yeah like maybe i can
get bottom of the barrel susie that
lives on my block who's been obsessed
with me since i'm five years old to come
over for a you know i'll pick for a pity
lay on her part or i just i know that i
can get that at the bottom of the barrel
easy pickings but when it comes to i
think you're getting
sympathetic there because i too at one
time wanted
you know all of these beautiful
hollywood sort of actresses that you'd
idealize and sort of pedestalize and
then here you are at 20 years old
what do you got you got a heart on
that's it you got nothing else you got
no money you got no game you're not that
interesting you live at your parents
house right
i mean yeah i do come down hard but i
come down hard for a reason man i mean
like i was i was that kid like i was the
kid with the buck teeth with the stutter
third degree burns on his neck in his
chest you know like the bad haircut
because my mom would cut my hair sort of
thing and then my hair started falling
out when i turned in my 20s it's like oh
this is great right so it's like well i
guess my main point is so i got it i'm
fat too right
oh yeah i was 100 pounds overweight or
100 probably
about 100 pounds more than i am now
though no i'm probably about 200 pounds
now upon some weight over christmas i
got i got the uh i got the rona so i'm
fighting that crap off okay
everyone everyone got it like like uh
rich i know a couple of guys in your
group mentioned it and just out of
nowhere although you know what it's it's
the typical cold it's just it just
lingers forever it just doesn't go away
but it's just a cold yeah
sorry muff you're just about no i think
i don't know i think my only point and
i'm trying to see i'm trying to keep an
eye on the chat is there a buzz on my
audio these are not the best headphones
it's yeah there's a buzz only when
you're not talking okay um i'll go back
to meeting back and forth i'm not sure
what that's about but i i guess those
things like no no like don't get me
wrong i'm not being easy on these guys
i'm not trying to be uh saying oh like
guys have a tough out there or like oh
it's okay no no no
i i guess for me i think a lot of guys
don't a lot of guys think they
overestimate how much work they have to
actually do i think
most guys are
six months to a year
of focused hard work in the core areas
of being exactly where they want to be
but to them
it just seems so astronomical
astronomically far away and far apart so
much easier just to say ah screw it like
if they can't get it immediately it's
the generation of um instant
gratification right the idea of having
delayed gratification for six months to
a year and then potentially living the
life you want to live for the next 30 or
40 or 50 or however long
they just can't seem to wrap their heads
around that
yeah it's
it's
it's just bizarre though dude like i
just i just
really
like i get it i was there i got the
t-shirt
you know had all the frustration
all the calls that come in you know the
anxiety with like the first you know the
first time being with a girl you know
like how to get a girl to talk to you
how to do it and it's all these sort of
things it's like you know what
you can focus on all the reasons why
things aren't happening for you
or you can focus on the things that are
going to get you closer to the results
and if you just paint a nice clear
picture
of what that new version of you looks
like like
jared i want to ask you because i mean
like losing weight is hard you know and
and and yeah it sucks
you guys saw it it's easier to keep it
off yeah like you guys saw jiren's um
you know like instagram earlier like the
guy is fit he's jacked right so
you lost all of that weight and you kept
it off and you developed a look and
style and you went from not getting good
results to getting good results how long
did that take
oh god i break it into a couple chapters
so i lost all the weight initially when
i was like 17. um i lost like 100 pounds
in one year
and i had a girlfriend at the time which
one thing i think a lot of these guys
don't realize like some of the guys like
blackpill guys in the chat or people
asking questions is thinking back i did
have girls that liked me even when i was
fat i didn't realize it because i had
such crap self-esteem but once i lost
all the weight i had i um i ended up
getting a girlfriend who sat next to me
in like junior
my junior year am lit class in high
school but she liked me back when i was
fat it's just that i didn't think that i
could really give much or have much to
offer to her because i was so so much
overweight but um the minute i lost the
weight i asked her out and she said
she's like yeah i've been waiting for a
while for that um
yeah so it was a mindset thing but so
the first time i lost the weight it's
like 100 pounds in one year and then i
fell into the trap that a lot of guys
fall into where i i kept going to the
gym i kept thinking i was dieting but i
didn't track anything didn't track my
list didn't know what was going in my
mouth so i was kind of skinny fat for a
while and then about six or seven years
ago is where i got really serious in the
gym uh where
um i decided to start having goals and
objectives milestones started
i started putting plans together like
nine like 90 day transformation plans so
um did the initial bulk put on like 15
pounds lean muscle mass of course put on
15 pounds of fat too and then i had to
cut that off and then it was really just
back and forth until i figured out how
to get lean and then stay lean but once
i got to the point where i actually just
liked the way i looked then then it was
game over i don't have to do much
anymore i haven't been in the gym in
almost two weeks because i have kovit
and like i've got a little pudge but i
still have an outline of my abs i was
talking to my family of the day like
it's
it once i got to the point where i've
been fit for longer than i was ever fat
that that's my new it's my body's new
set point like it's actually hard for me
to get fat now which is nice it's it's
really nice
did you get your audio cleaned up um off
or you just muted yourself yeah i think
he's still muted
but yeah i think i think a lot of guys
rich what you're saying i think they do
overestimate how long it takes and a lot
of these guys like some of the guys that
called in earlier i'm like okay like
if it's an effect of like trimming a
beard or like you know uh bringing in
the haircut or a lot of times it's just
personality too i think um because i
remember again back to
phases during my transformation where
like i've always i've always gotten laid
it's just the question is am i getting
laid with the kind of girls i want to
get laid with and what sort of effort am
i putting into it and
verse what i'm getting out of it and i
think that's where
a lot of guys aren't where they where
they want to be but a lot a lot of guys
can get laid because most guys out there
just aren't in the game to begin with
yeah i mean like one of the common
themes that i've noticed anyway doing
this and i've done i don't know how many
call-ins now um probably over a thousand
but um
like there was a guy last week you know
for example the guy that was five six
and 210 pounds he's in our group right
and he's like oh you know i'm a few
pounds overweight or like a hair of
weight or something like that it's like
no no no you're 210 and you're five six
that's not a healthy weight like that's
fat like unless you're lee priest
bodybuilder you know build you know sort
of thing you're carrying the weight and
you can see
you know see in your face it's like the
guy you know with the
instagram comment on my thread where he
said like you know i've done all the
work i've read your book and it's just
not working that's like really because
you don't have an influential social
media
like
nothing like zero posts
nothing right
it's here's the guy that's you know
showing you know the world that he's
interesting and that he does fun stuff
right
yeah right i upload a guitar reel and i
get like 100 new followers which
i will be the first person to admit that
i'm not a musician it's something i
enjoy doing that i want to get better at
but
i put it out there and it works so i
just keep putting it out there
yeah women like creative guys i mean
i i've i've personally underestimated
the value of
being able to play a musical instrument
like i used to just you know dismiss it
like whatever you know women don't like
these artists guys you know like they
like money they like muscle sort of
thing but it's like no no women dude
like guys that have the ability to
strum a guitar and put some lyrics
together or dude i get last minute
resistance when a girl comes over i'm
just like hey that's fine you know i'm
just gonna do what i'd normally do on
any other given night pull out the
guitar like two or two or three songs in
yeah it get game over yeah
so don't get a motorcycle get a guitar
yeah and you probably won't get hurt
anything else you get free entertainment
value out of it too
yeah
well guitar is super yeah definitely
learn that even if the most you can
learn some cowboy chords and learn how
to play i mean you can play 70 song with
70 songs with four basic chords if you
can just learn a very
simple uh progression but i think what i
wanted to add it's all the top songs
right and they know him and they sing
along and it's fine i mean
i i think i love hearing guys that are
like
oh i've done all the work or i've done
this i've read this and hasn't worked i
think i go back to my own personal
experience
and
for everybody that no anecdote it's a
personal experience yadda yadda but you
know i do it a lot of guys in the group
do it guys that i've run into they're
still always their number one biggest
critic and they're like i always have
they they recognize they still have work
to do and they always will the guys are
like i've done the work i've read the
book i don't know and like nothing's
working for me i got no patience for
those guys i mean i remember being on
with you and aaron clary back
in february or so and i'm like yeah i'm
doing this and doing that and i was like
i feel like i'm a 5 out of 10 and you
guys are like i think you're selling
yourself maybe a little bit short and
even some guys in the comments were
saying something similar but
those are the guys that i want to be
around and align myself with guys that
underestimate you know their value so
they're always having that drive to
continue working because that's how we
build off each other and that's how you
really foster that community and that
try like i don't want somebody to say
i've done we've run into i've run into
guys that are like well i've done this
i've done that and nothing works so i
might as well give up and it's all [ __ ]
okay see ya uh no patience for those
guys
you you don't have to convince me like
to to
you're not gonna i'm not gonna work for
you right if you if you're not coming to
me saying i know i have work to help me
get there then i got no time for you
yeah those guys are the best the ones
like okay bro i'm i'm working harder to
get you laid than you are like
or i i hate this maf i think i mentioned
this on our last stream um especially
i'm in the states now but when i'm in
mexico like when another gringo comes up
it's like oh hey man can you translate
for me i'm like oh god like i'm gonna
hear a terrible game in one ear and then
i'm gonna spit good game in spanish to
this girl and she's going to want me and
then i'm going to be in the middle and
this guy's going to be like hey man what
happened what why didn't i get the girl
like no i don't i don't do that yeah
that's true
you